spoiler alerts no one is safe when your
favorite TV show wants to make an impact
it's pretty much guaranteed that your
favorite character is going to die
everyone is expendable when it comes to
generating buzz and 2016 was an
especially rough year for TV death after
you're done watching our first video
about TV's most recent dearly deceased
prepare yourself for some more spoilers
with some of the most upsetting TV
deaths of 2016 barbs in spite of being a
collection of warm 80s nostalgia the
award-winning stranger things is
decidedly at home in today's TV
landscape it's not afraid to kill off
its characters and that includes
innocent nerdy children the Netflix hit
raised the stakes pretty high when the
show's resident Milhouse lonely geeky
barb was suddenly taken by the flower
faced bees from the upside down sure her
death gave her best friend Nancy and
Will's brother Jonathan a reason to team
up and go monster hunting but not soon
enough to save poor barb who was pretty
much forgotten for the rest of the
season season few promises to get
justice for barb however according to
the duffer brothers the show's creators
who say an inmate at Litchfield since
the start of the Netflix dramedy who say
was a fan favorite with a particularly
heartbreaking back story in season four
who stays started a relationship with
fellow inmates also as well as a
friendship with jailed TV chef Judy King
who promised her a job upon release
things were looking up but tragedy
struck from out of the blue during a
peaceful protest in the cafeteria a
scuffle breaks out and poussey is killed
when a guard restrained her accidentally
crushing her windpipe with his knees and
killing her Abe and Glenn millions tuned
into the season 6 finale of The Walking
Dead for the moment in which the gang
met up with the comic books most
notorious villain negan it was pretty
much guaranteed that at the end of the
episode
negan would beat someone to death with
his fat Lucille and he did we just
didn't get to see it you can breathe you
can like
you can cry yeah you're all going to be
doing that
it wasn't until halfway through the
season 7 premiere that we found out
negan killed two fan favorite Abe and
Glenn of course it wasn't that simple
Abe was murdered first and just when
viewers thought they could breathe a
sigh of relief for Glenn who was Meighan
victim in the comics Darrel responded to
Abraham's death by punching Meighan in
the face so bad guy unleashed another
dose of murderous violence not against
Daryl but Glenn the brutality and the
teasing way in which the episode old it
out were perfectly in keeping with the
Walking Dead's overall arc but it was
all still too much for more than a few
viewers to handle Robert Ford HBO's
Westworld revolves around several main
characters who pretty much constantly
die and come back to life mostly because
almost everybody is a hyper-realistic
humanoid robot controlled by the
mysterious and calculating chief robot
god Robert Ford
at the end of West world's complicated
and engrossing first season he program
series star Dolores to shoot him in the
head why in order to demonstrate that he
was finally liberating his robots and
giving them control of West worlds while
it's always possible that it was just a
robot version of Ford that died it isn't
likely that an actor with the stature of
Sir Anthony Hopkins would be sticking
around series television for long so
we're going to call him dead for now
Jodie Hubbard CBS 2 sitcom mom is a show
about people struggling with substance
abuse and recovery so it makes sense
that a relapse related death would be
part of the story even if the show is
still a laugh track driven comedy Jodie
was a teenage addict in recovery for
whom Christy served as an Alcoholics
Anonymous sponsor in February 2016
mom aired a fairly standard wedding
episode but at the end Chris he gets a
phone call from police telling her that
Jodie had died from a drug overdose
according to co-creator Chuck Lorre
killing off Jodie had been the plan for
the character since the beginning to
show that not all recovery stories have
a happy ending Edward Meechum at first
just a temporary bodyguard for Frank
Underwood Edward Meechum was a loyal
stoic and reliable presence he was even
officially promoted to the
Secret Service when Frank Underwood
became vice-president and then president
sadly Edward died in the line of duty
protecting the president when reporter
turned cyber terrorists Lucas Goodwin
opened fire at a speaking engagement the
president took two bullets but it was
Meacham who suffered fatal gunshot
wounds he died right then and there but
not before taking out Goodwin Ron's a
lion killing off a main character in a
season premiere so do you think you are
Empire The Walking Dead in the season 2
finale that aired in May 2015
audiences were left wondering about the
outcome of a fight between Anika and
Rhonda when somebody falls off a balcony
five months later audiences saw Rhonda's
body embedded in a car however while
Raja is definitely dead the character
may not be showrunners had said that
Andre will have an unusual relationship
with his dead wife so there's a good
chance we'll get dream sequences
hallucinations and ghostly apparition
Empire is after all a soap opera Jax
Pearson as one of the biggest hits of
the fall 2016 TV season millions tune
into this is odd if only to figure out
what the cryptic promotional campaign
was getting at what was the connection
between a couple having a baby in
hospital another couple slowly falling
in love a sitcom actor and an adult man
confronting someone who appeared to be
his father because the show unfolds over
the course of three decades character
deaths are a given but one of them is
pretty startling it's revealed that Milo
Ventimiglia Jack isn't part of any
modern storylines because he died and
was cremated at some point in the past
because of the way the show is presented
we'll still see plenty of Jack still
it's pretty sad for audiences knowing
what he doesn't know that he won't live
to see his kids grow up Margaery and
Tommen after falling under the control
of the high Sparrow everything went up
in green flames for Margaery her life
becoming collateral damage at the hands
of her vengeful mother-in-law Cersei
Lannister blew up the whole of King's
Landing with some heretofore
undiscovered wildfire and Cersei son
King Tommen was pretty upset after the
death of his bride so he went for a walk
out a window
ah well thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to